I think they look at you like a guy who
they're worried about because you don't
tow the line they should be exctly
you're like a '90s
liberal you're like liberals back when
they're more reasonable before they
became leftists and now every liberal
kind of has to be a leftist it's not
it's like if you want to be on the team
you got to subscribe to the most Fringe
ideas that the team is promoting I have
always believed as liberals do for
example in a colorblind society that the
goal is to not see race at all anywhere
for any reason that's not what the woke
believe they believe race is first and
foremost the thing you should always see
everywhere which I find interesting
because that used to be the position of
the Kooks Clan if you Bill Maher and you
Joe Rogan if you want to live in that
colorblind Society you cannot vote for
Democrats you cannot